last time I talked to you we had a great
conversation at the end of the
conversation you urged me to go to Haiti
so I did took my camera crew
we went and shot a show there and I had
one of the most amazing experiences of
my life so thank you for for encouraging
me to do that well life changing thank
you for doing it I I was there just
shortly after your trip and I saw that
you did a great show and and the timing
of it was exceptional in response to
some unkind words that the President had
said about Haiti among other countries
and there you know like in any culture
there are people that are more sensitive
than others to these things some it kind
of is water off a duck's back sort of
when the a thing like that has said but
I knew many people for whom it was a
very painful attack on their pride yeah
and the that you went down was very
important to them and that you came and
and brought your humor and shared it
with them gave them that stage it was a
it was an important thing so thank you
well I absolutely I love being there the
people the people the people are so
funny they're so full of life they're so
five asia's and it is interesting when
you say that because we're so used in
this country you know president says
something and you think well okay a
country will hear it but you think of it
as a country not people when you go
there and we had the same experience we
went to Mexico after some after a
campaign that that the president are now
president ran pretty much against Mexico
and the Mexican people I went down there
for that show and just as in Haiti I
found real people whose feelings were
hurt
on a human level and when you talk to
them about it you realize it's people
it's its people its people and and it's
also people who if they have a love for
a particular country outside their own
it's ours yeah and for a leader to not
recognize that and to not respect that
and appreciate it it's disappointing you
know was amazing to me
when we were in Haiti you went right
after the 2010 quake hit and I don't
think people in this country still can
appreciate the magnitude of that quake
and how many people lost their lives and
how decimated port-au-prince was and and
the areas around port-au-prince just
devastated and I was curious you went
there and you saw that happen how long
were you there after the earthquake you
were there I mean you were living in the
country for quite a long time we were
living in a tent camp adjacent the
largest tent just internally displaced
person camp I I was but for a few days
over the course of it I was living nine
months yeah
therefore the first stretch and then
going back you know back and forth quite
a bit while the organization j/p HRO was
building itself and I there were there
was that now fortunately we we had
started with 30 Americans yeah and now
we have about six or seven Americans and
the total crew of over 100 sometimes
with day workers over a thousand yeah
and all Haitian and all Haitian run and
they're doing an extraordinary job you
know what's incredible yeah they are
that the work that we know is amazing
but also on a personal note we are crew
we were driving everywhere there was not
a single part of Haiti or port-au-prince
that we were able to get to where people
didn't I didn't see one area where they
didn't say yeah Sean was here about a
year ago he fixed my bike tire you know
like it's almost like you're everywhere
some of them seem annoyed he was here
again asking if he could do anything for
us if we told him please go away for a
bit I wanted to end on a positive note
about Haiti which was my I don't know if
you agree I was there and I've been to
many places in the world where I felt
whether it's the West Bank whether it's
Syria I think I don't know that there's
a solution here if there is I don't know
what it is it's not in my power to think
of it Haiti seems like the problems
there are solvable it feel
like it's great people beautiful natural
resources and yes they need help and yes
there's a lot of work to be done but it
does feel like in 20 years that could be
a very different place well I think you
know when you look at the history
because Haiti has has certainly
presented a case and why Haiti I mean
was a lot of help and intervention
holding it back as well but they
presented a case that seems to be this
kind of treadmill but in fact now what
happens in a lot of cultures is that
they that people come to accept the the
too little that they have but over time
between the human necessity of dreams
being fulfilled and particularly for
their kids where they spent forty five
percent of their annual income on their
education that that this generation of
kids who are now interconnected and see
how the other side lives see what's
available in this world and they're
sharing that with each other I think all
of us that are working there have a
great optimism that in our lifetime
we're going to see tremendous change in
Haiti and the kind that might be done in
a way replicable to some other places
that are similarly suffering so we have
only great hope there
you